okay so as people are
uh
kind of meandering in let me start the
seminar off and i'm shafieli the
director of the simons institute
and as uh i think most of you know uh
the simons institute is an international
venue for collaborative research
in theoretical computer science
established in 2012 with a very generous
grant from the simons foundation
and
it's my great pleasure to welcome you to
the third talk in a new series which we
call the breakthrough lecture series we
launched it past summer
and it highlights substantial advances
in the field of threat of computer
science and this talk qualifies big time
but before i introduce the speaker
i want to sort of talk about
the
question and answer ethically here so we
have people in the audience here at
simon's and if you want to ask a
question just kind of pipe up and i will
give you the mic
and everybody can hear it um i think
people offline
namely learn in the auditorium are all
in webinar form
and the way they ask questions is by
putting them in a q a
and as i notice them i will kind of
alert really to the
questions
um
and i think uh
it's time to introduce elite so our
speaker today is uh professor ryrie dino
was educated in tel aviv university he
got both abs and a phd in tel aviv
and then she came for postdoc at
berkeley actually she was a miller
she was in the miller institute and also
a postdoc in the advanced study
institute in princeton
uh and a neck research institute in
princeton and she then
went to hebrew university where she was
a senior lecturer before joining the
weizmann institute where she is now
she
was also a fellow at harvard university
i guess the william bentik smith fellow
and uh she's also been a visiting
professor there and visiting professor
at is
she is a plenary speaker in icm an
international congress of mathematicians
in 2010
she's received numerous awards and
honors including the girdle prize the
acm
pods
test of time award
uh levinson prize in mathematics
erdos prize in mathematics and the anna
nadiv bruno
research award and her research
interests are in complexity theory in
probably checkable proofs error
correcting codes
and uh there are many of their
applications
uh today these days she is interested in
connecting these two
high dimensional expansion
some an analog of expanded graphs on
which she actually ran a cluster
a few summers ago at simons when we were
still in person and it was a very
interesting cluster with visitors from
around the world
but elite doesn't only do complexity
theory she has really for example she
and um kobe nisim have had actually the
first paper that launched uh
uh differential privacy uh what became
the french privacy later and many other
um
you know breakthrough results
today she's talking about locally
testable codes with constant rate
distance and locality which was sort of
a coveted result for a long time
so uh please join me in welcoming elite
and uh the floor is yours
wow okay thank you very much
such a nice introduction and okay
i'll start the talk um
thanks for inviting me to give this talk
it's a very very new result it's based
on joint work with shai evra ronnie
alex luboski and shahal moses
and i want to thank also the graphic
designer who made this beautiful
graphics hopefully
when the talk progresses the graphic
will make a bit more sense
uh okay so let's start by talking about
locally testable codes these are error
correcting codes
uh for me for us in this talk it's just
gonna be linear error correcting code so
it's just a linear vector space over 0 1
and the
parameters that people always talk about
are the rate and the distance the rate
is just the dimension of this vector
space normalized divided by n
and the distance is the number of
non-zero bits in the lowest weight code
word that's not zero and again we divide
by n
so when we say constant rate and
distance we mean that
this is a positive number
greater than zero and we're always
thinking about an infinite family where
n goes to infinity but the rate is
always going to be at least some point
one or maybe point nine
and we will see
so these are very very standard
parameters i'm not going to talk about
them anymore local testability is less
standard maybe it's you know in some
circles but uh
but uh let me define it nevertheless so
uh code c is called locally testable
with q queries
if there is an algorithm that we call a
tester algorithm this algorithm has
access to
an input the a word but it doesn't read
the input instead it's given just query
access so it tosses some coins then it
decides on some queue locations in the
word and it only reads these queue
locations and based on the values there
it decides to say yes or no except the
reject
and it satisfies the following two
properties first of all if the word is
in the code then uh the algorithm is
always going to accept even though it's
only reading q bits it's going to always
say yes
if
the input is not in the code
then
we can't really expect the algorithm to
reject with high probability because
it's only reading a few bits and maybe
the code word was only slightly
uh
tampered with so the only realistic
thing we can expect is that the
rejection probability is proportional to
the distance of the word from the code
and that's uh what we require here so
this is uh one variant of local
testability there are several other ones
this one is the strongest so i'm going
to just stick to
this definition
q the number of bits that the tester
reads is called the locality
uh of course the smaller queue is kind
of the more impressive the result
because
the algorithm really is not looking at
almost anything it's only looking at a
number of bits and still making a
decision that
will is is going to be meaningful so um
smaller quality is kind of
better
okay let me tell you a little bit about
the the history of the locally testable
codes
already to tell you whereas
shannon already in his seminal paper
proved that a random
parity-check matrix will have good rate
and distance
he couldn't have conceived of a locally
testable codes because random codes
don't have this property and really
the the only natural way i can imagine
of coming up with this definition is
through the
kind of the the journey through the
probabilistically checkable proofs which
is indeed how this came about
so locally testable codes were studied
implicitly in early works on
probabilistically checkable proofs and
program checking in the very early 90s
whether these pcps tell you that any
np proof can be encoded
into a pcp proof another proof that can
be
locally checked like you want to locally
check a code word
and when you try to prove such a theorem
and you try to construct these pcp
encodings you're naturally encoding your
np proof
using some encodings and you imagine
that the prover is giving you this
encoding and there is a verification
procedure that needs to check that
whatever the approver is giving you is
actually a correct encoding so it's
almost built into the definition of pcp
it's not really but
it feels very similar to
and indeed that's how it works out pcp's
when you construct them you want to use
locally testable codes uh to encode the
proof of first you need other properties
as well
so uh this is indeed how things went and
uh during those years people really
discovered the
the incredible power of low degree
functions and polynomials
and they used them for various
properties and it was
it's really fantastic
what a diverse set of properties they
load with functions at and in particular
low degree tests show you that uh
polynomial codes like the removal code
is locally testable
and
even works that deal with these objects
uh locally that's the records more
generally were also defined
um
dan spielman in his phd thesis he worked
on expander codes we which we're going
to describe soon
in more details and also on pcps and in
his phd pieces he kind of writes about
an object that combines the two
the two together and this is kind of a
nice
paragraph that i want to read
so he writes this a checker and here he
refers to a local tester like what we
just defined in the previous uh slide
a checker would be able to read
only a constant number of bits of a
received signal this is the input word
and then estimate the chance that the
decoder will be able to to correct the
errors
then the checker can instantly request a
retransmission of that block before the
decoder has wasted its time trying to
decode the message
unfortunately unknown codes with local
checkers have rate approaching zero
i find this really nice because it
captures exactly a kind of a wonderful
application of locally
testable codes right you kind of
transmit the encoding but instead of
worrying about decoding which might take
some time just
randomly do some checks and if you see
that there's too many errors you can
already ask for a reason so that's kind
of very cool
of course since uh no ltcs were known
with constant rate
this doesn't meet the kind of the golden
standard of coding theory and codes with
a right approaching zero are typically
considered not
realistic
um
okay
so this was in the 90s and then a few
years later
golovkin sudan started a more systematic
study of locally testable codes as
objects of interest on their own and
they also put on the table the question
of what's the highest possible rate
of a locally testable code
in this third sequence of works
that constructed both locally testable
codes
and pcps with length growing shorter and
shorter so you always compare the length
of the message and the length of the
encoding so in tcps you compare the
length of the
np witness to the length of the vcp
witness and all of these words that i
kind of quickly wrote here
construct both objects with length
shrinking and shrinking and shrinking
and the state of the art is to have
constant distance and constant locality
but the rate is one over poly long so
that's
going to zero as the block length
increases but it's still not so bad
and at that point people were already
talking about you know whether or not
it's possible to get locally testable
codes that are so-called good good being
constant rate and distance which is like
the standard of coding theory and
uh later we change the name to instead
of saying good which is kind of a vague
uh
describe
a description uh we change it to c3 for
constant rate constant distance and
constant locality and there was a lot of
doubt about you know can you even
construct such objects maybe you can
maybe you can't unclear and people
started working also on lower bounds
trying to prove that code with certain
properties cannot exist or it must have
high rate
i myself was involved in one of these
works but all of the lower bounds was
were restricted
another line of work said okay let's say
go from the other direction let's insist
on the rate being a constant and see
what's the smallest possible locality we
can get
and these words are also nice because
they kind of abandoned the whole pcp
paradigm and said we're just going to
focus on
on codes
and using expanders they actually got
constant rates constant distance and
locality that is slightly larger than
poly log n it's quasi polylogin
i want to also mention another a thread
involved in the property testing of all
these algebraic codes which was uh
interested in understanding what makes a
all these algebraic codes and other
algebraic properties locally testable
and the role of the symmetries here it's
affinitarians
was
highlighted and proven that any property
that is
has all these symmetries is going to be
locally testable
the most recent research direction in in
in this area is the research direction
of the high dimensional expansion
here
high dimensional expanders are these
wonderful objects that are
based on some
very
broad or
a wide variety of mathematics
and
i first learned about them from
kaufman they exhibit
really interesting local global features
and i'm going to talk about this more or
later but just to say that
it was clear that these objects might be
very useful for property testing
and maybe even for constructing locally
testable codes and as jeffy mentioned
earlier we even had a
a
summer cluster on this topic called the
high dimensional expanders and codes
and i put this slide on because i really
like the graphic that barry made for us
here you see that they put like the the
geometric structure the graph with the
triangle so it's like a high dimensional
object and on top of it you have the
bits of the code so it was already clear
that we're trying to build codes on top
of some high dimensional objects
and the current work that i'm now
talking about
is going to be
along these lines
okay so the main result is
is this there exists constants say r the
rate delta the distance in q the
locality and an exclusive construction
of an infinite family of aircraft in
codes with the radar distance delta and
locally testable queue queries
um
okay
so now i want to
start the
more
technical part of the talk it's
hopefully going to be
supposed to be self-contained so please
do
interrupt with questions if i can't hear
you then someone can help me here
okay so my plan is this i'm first going
to talk about expander codes which many
of us
know very well
but i'm going to describe them in in
some detail just to make it easier to
describe
the new codes which really are a second
layer on top of the expander code so
it'll be very useful for us
uh then i'm going to define a new object
that we call the left right k
a complex
and this is really like a graph that has
an extra layer of squares this is the
second the second dimension thing uh
after defining this object this graph of
squares we're going to define the code
on the
square complex and then we're going to
analyze some of the properties
okay so let's begin
uh i want to talk about expander code so
uh
i guess
historically it makes sense to first
mention the low density parity check
codes
of gallagher
uh but in interest of time let me just
already talk about
uh
tanner codes which are a generalization
of
the ldbc codes
in taylor code you are presented with a
bipartite graph called the factor graph
and we see it over here
and
the bits of the code or the code word is
going to be placed on the vertices of
the graph over here so you put 0 1 1 0
and so on
and the constraints are the vertices on
the right each vertex looks at all of
its neighbors it sees a little local
view of the entire code word and it
requires that this local view belongs to
some base code so there is some
okay
there is some base code
c naught here
and
pardon me until i get the
okay it looks okay
there is some bass code um
c note and you require that the bit
you require that the bits that this guy
is seeing uh are in the base code
i don't know why it's suddenly happening
because
all right
okay
okay maybe you can see here um in the
bottom right corner i wrote down the
tenor code it's all the words labeling
the left-hand vertices
such that for every vertex on the right
the kind of local picture that it sees
is in the base code that's a tanner code
and to tell me to specify a specific
tanner code what you need to tell me are
two things one what is the structure of
your factor graph what's the bipartite
graph and two what is the base code and
once you give me these two things i know
what the tenor body is
so sister and skillman
constructed such a tanner codes
uh in a very beautiful way using
explicit expander graphs and what they
did was they took an expander graph and
they used it to construct this factor
graph
and this is what i'm going to show now
in the next slide
so here are the situation codes
you start out with a d regular lambda
expander graph g
now i'm not going to formally define
lambda expander but let me just say for
those of us who know
you look at the adjacency matrix of the
graph and you look at the eigenvalues
and if all the eigenvalues except the
top one or below lambda i'm thinking of
now about normalized eigenvalues then
you call the graph a lambda extender and
we know of
explicit families of such expanders so
you can construct them in polynomial
time deterministically and so on
you take such a graph
if you're not so familiar with this
graph let me just say that these are
graphs that
on one hand every vertex only sees d
neighbors so they're very sparse but on
the other hand they're very well
connected no matter how you split the
vertices into two parts there's going to
be many many edges crossing between the
parts
okay so you take this graph and you put
the bits of the code on the edges of the
graph okay so here are the bits of the
code
and
you take a base
base code and the length of the base
code is going to be d the regularity of
the graph the constraints are going to
say for every vertex i want to look at
all the edges touching vertex and have
them belong if the bits that i see there
belong to the base code so you can see
down here the factor the factor graph
let's see if this is going to work for
me the factor graph over here
uh you can see that for every edge i put
a vertex on the left and for every
vertex here i put a vertex on the right
and this part is just looks at all of
the edges touching it and sees that
these bits belong to the baseboard
okay so this is quite
standard
and let me
quickly run through the analysis because
it's so beautiful that you can
really do the analysis of these graphs
uh
uh very very elegantly
so sorry to disturb just to make sure
because you're starting to dive in terms
of terminology
so the code here is a set of functions
yeah it's
a
which map edges to
two bits
yeah
with mapping edges to bits you just
think that every edge is labeled by a
zero or a one
okay
every edge is labeled by zero or one and
the constraint is that if you look
around a vertex
then you see here you know one one one
one
this uh this string of length four needs
to be in the basically
okay let me try to
see how many code words are in this code
what's the dimension of this
space of code words in
[Music]
by just simple linear algebra
so how many uh functions do i have
one on the edges well the dimension is
the number of edges two to the number of
edges is the number of functions
so the dimension the ambient dimensions
is just the number of edges
now
my code has some linear constraints so
i'm going to count how many linear
constraints i have and this will
restrict how many functions i end up
having in my code
so how many constraints do i have
for every vertex
in g
i have a bunch of constraints
these are the constraints that say the
edges around this vertex need to be in c
naught
how many constraints are there this is
exactly the number this is the number of
constraints to define the code the small
code synonym so i have this many linear
constraints per every vertex
so the total dimension is the number of
edges minus
this number of constraints and you just
do the calculation and you see that it's
the number of edges
times two are not minus one
so this becomes positive as long as r
naught is above a half
so as long as your base code has rate
above a half this definition makes sense
and the code is going to have
a
linear dimension
okay now what about uh the distance
erase some of the
clutter
to prove this sense you really rely on
the expansion so if you understand just
a little bit the spectral expansion
proving distance is really a piece of
cake
let's say not go through the proof but
let's just
think about it intuitively
uh if i want to prove distance i need to
think of some code word that's not all
zeros okay so it's some code word it has
some
a non-zero edge right so for example
this edge
has a one on it
so now i look at one of the vertices one
of the end points of the edge and i see
that
it already has one a single one on it so
it means that the word around this
vertex is a non-zero word so there must
be delta naught times the other ones so
this must be a one this must be a one
okay so now i can move to these three
vertices okay each one of them touches a
non-zero edge so again it must have a
few
non-zero edges and this propagates and
propagates and propagates and using the
expander mixing layer or the elon
channel
you see that the code has distance
so are you ready are some questions in
the chat if you can just quickly
a specific question on this slide i
think
okay
can i see it on the q and a i think you
can see
should there be n edges as well since
we're on
m here is the number of edges
and just denotes the number of edges in
the in the graph yeah that's a good
question so usually n denotes the number
of vertices but here
n is going to be the number of edges the
number of
edges
here this is n
and this is going to be so n will be the
number of edges
and the number of vertices is the i
don't know what letter to use for it
and there's another question here is
should there be an order on the edges
ah that's a good question
uh
yeah okay let me let me answer that
um
every vertex when i say that a vertex
looks at its edges and
sees a bunch of bits here it's going to
see one zero one
how does it
know what it needs to have in order on
the edges to know
how to
associate this with a string of three
bits right so
we we can assume here i am just doing it
implicitly that the vertex has some
arbitrary order on each each vertex has
an order on its edges
okay any more questions
how small can i make you
uh okay i don't i don't know and let's
talk about this at the end
okay
uh so
um
one of the you know the wonderful
aspects of these expander codes is that
not only do they have constant rate and
distance
they actually allow for a
formal proof of linear time decoding
and not going to go into it here but
this is a really really cool
algorithm
uh
for for me what we care about today i'm
going to talk about the local disability
of these codes
are they locally testable
so the answer is uh
no
typically they're not going to be
locally testable and i want to spend
this slide to explain why they're not
globally testament okay
so firstly let's say observe that when i
define the tanner code i said that you
give me a
factor graph and then every check node
checks that you belong to some c naught
the but really there's no reason to put
the same c naught at every location we
can define the
the expander codes so that you know this
vertex
will look will ask whether these bits
belong to one base code and this vertex
can ask whether these bits belong to
another baseball
nothing in the analysis will change we
just count the linear constraints and we
use the fact that the base codes have
distance at least some dead or not so
that's going to still be legal
okay so now we can
do kind of a thought experiment think of
the expander code as we define them and
then choose one vertex say this this guy
call it v0
and on v0 you're going to uh
on v0 you're going to
just remove one of the constraints
okay so you remove one of the
constraints
and the the code the c0 on this vertex
only is slightly larger it has double
the number of words
okay
now what happens to the global code
typically all of the constraints are
linearly independent from each other so
when you removed one constraint the
entire global code doubled in size the
dimension increased by one
so what does this mean it means that now
new code words have appeared
new code words have appeared but still
all of the analysis goes through in
particular the distance so all of the
new code words together
satisfy that they are all very far from
each other in particular look at one new
code word it's far from all of the old
code words
what does it mean far it means that it's
far uh
by a linear number of bits from all of
the old code words
but on the other hand it satisfies all
of the constraints of the new code which
means that it satisfies you know it
satisfies this constraint and this
constraint it satisfies all of the
constraints except for these constraints
the only one that it doesn't satisfy is
the constraint on v0
okay so this is a
a problem right it's a code word that's
far but it violates only one constraint
it's a nightmare for proving located
stability it's like the worst counter
example it's very very far and satisfies
almost almost everything
where was the problem the problem was we
were able to change one constraint and
increase the code there was no
connection between different constraints
and in the codes that we will construct
even if you remove some constraint
locally it won't affect the code because
the constraints will themselves be
dependent on each other
so
we will see this
questions before i move to the
so so far we basically talked about kind
of well-known things
uh now i want to move to the
one level up so now i want to talk about
pushing expander code to the next
dimension basically
if we previously had a factor graph with
vertices and edges now we're going to
add
squares that's like faces of one more
dimension up and if previously we had
the bits here
and the constraints here
now we're going to move the bits to the
squares and move the constraints to the
edges see the bits are here and the
constraints are here
and the vertices they're going to supply
us with dependencies among the
constraints we will see that
okay so how do we do that we have in our
mind a graph that not only has vertices
and edges it also has these uh four
cycles that we call squares
and there's going to be some factor
graph like we have here on the right
okay
so let's define such an object before i
define it i want to define a caylee
graph this is a very very standard
object but just to be sure
to define a telegraph you start with the
finite group g
and the set a of elements
we assume that it's closed under taking
inverses so if a is in the set a inverse
is in the set
and from these you build a graph you put
vertices for every element in the group
you put a vertex
and you connect a vertex g to a vertex a
times g
these are the edges notice that it's an
undirected graph because if you're at
vertex a times g and you multiply by a
inverse you move to a inverse times a
times g which is back to g
so it's an undirected brush
this is very standard cable
now what are we doing that's slightly
slightly different we're going to take
two calligraphs one with the set of
elements b a and one with the set of
elements
b
okay
okay for that
okay
so
uh we're going to have two categories
cayley graph of g and a
is the graph with this set of edges from
g to a g
and the k graph of g with b is another
graph with this set of edges from g to g
times b
there's a slight
difference between the a graph and the b
graph and the difference is that for the
a graph we multiply on the left a times
g and for the big graph we move multiply
on the right g times b
and what difference does this make
usually it makes no difference but here
it gives you this commutativity because
you can start from a vertex g
you can first take a red edge and then a
blue edge so first take in
a b edge and then an a edge or you can
first take an a edge and then a b edge
and you'll end up in the same location
so this gives you a lot of squares
okay and this is something we will build
on
here is the square so i highlighted it
and filled it to
emphasize the fact that we don't only
think of it as a cycle we think of the
square itself as an object
okay so let's look at it a bit more
closely focus on one a one vertex g
and two uh a generators a and b so a
takes me from g to a g
and b takes me from g to g b
okay and these two these three things a
b and g
this triple
defines for me a rooted square right
because it defines for me this square
but it also specifies the root g
right i mean the same square
it can also be defined by a different
triple right i can start from a g
here
and then i can take the generator a
inverse to move to
a inverse a g which is g
and i can use the generator b to move
here agp so this would correspond to
using a inverse
a g
and b so this is would correspond to
this triple which is the rooted square
which is the same square as we have in
the picture but with the root a g
okay so every square has four
different groups
right and uh
okay
question
yeah
there's a question uh in the chat um
the squares could be degenerate is that
a problem if g a
equals to g b g right thank you so uh
i don't think it's a problem but let's
for the talk
assume that this never happened so
that's a very good point so you could
potentially have that a g equals g b
in other words g inverse
if
a g equals b and let's just assume a
non-conjugate c condition
none of the a's are conjugate to none of
the b's so this never happens all the
squares are non-degenerate
good
good catch here
um
okay so uh
there's four different routes and uh
we're going to define a non unrooted
square or just a square we write it with
these
square brackets over here and it's just
this equivalence class of the four
rooted scores
okay so basically you have a all these
rooted squares and you bunch them into
small equivalence classes and these are
your squares
and the square naturally contains the
edges in the picture right so the edge g
to a g and the edge g to g b and so on
and these four vertices
and formally the set of squares is
exactly
the set of all triples a times g times b
divided by this equivalent equivalence
class relation
okay
questions
uh someone is asking aren't cary grass
usually defined on a billion groups
jihad is not a billion g can be a
billion but for us
we want the graph to be an expander and
you won't get any constant degree
expanders if g is a billion so no carry
graphs certainly are defined for all
groups also non-billion groups
i think this this object is also
interesting for a billion groups but uh
i mean
it's known that a billion booths require
a logarithmic number of generators to
become extenders
okay
so let's now summarize just the
definition of this complex
so we started with a finite group and we
took two sets
of generators
closed under inverses
i mean formally they don't need to be
generators the graph will just not be
connected but it's not so important
okay
and now we define the complex by the
following
three things the vertices are just the
group elements
the edges
are the
calligraph edges
the union of the two categories
and the squares are like we said the
equivalence classes
and we're going to say that this
kelly square complex
is a lambda expander if each one of the
caligraphs the a1 and the b1 are each
lambda expanders
and
all standard things in
that
people have already studied a lot
implied that for every lambda
you can get the explicit infinite
families of bounded degree
left right kelly complexes that are
lambda expanders the the only
non-trivial thing is if you
uh go back to that question about having
the squares non-degenerate you need this
non-conjugacy condition so you need to
work a little bit hard to come up with
sets of generators a and b
that satisfy this non-conjugate
condition
okay but uh
but
it's not so hard to construct
okay
so let me talk a little bit about some
properties of these complexes
okay so let's focus on one edge
connecting g to a g
who are the squares that touch this edge
so for any
b neighbor of g say gb1
there's also the same b neighbor for a g
aging agb1 and this will be
closing a square okay
you can see
kind of by picture that
the the set of squares touching a g are
like pages in a book
the spine is the edge gag and each page
is really labeled by one element from b
so these pages are kind of naturally
identified with b
symmetrically if you look at an edge
from g to g b
for the square is touching this edge
it's all the s
these squares are naturally identified
with a right this set from b g to g b is
like a spine and all the squares are
like
the pages in this book
so every edge has like a book of squares
around it
okay now let's look at the vertex and
what kind of squares touch a vertex
okay so this picture looks a bit scary
but let's go through it slowly
so
a vertex g
this guy
has the
neighbors for every element of a and for
every element of b right so let me
write it so i have here
a1
a2 maybe i call it
a1g
g
a three g this is the name of these
these vertices
and there's also the neighbors on the b
side this is g
b one
g b two
g b
three okay so this is the name of these
six vertices
now what are the smaller smaller dots in
here
these are not neighbors of g but they
are like the tips of the square so if i
choose say a3g in gb3
then they this makes a square you take
this edge
from g to g to a3 g and from g to g
b3 and then i can close the square like
this
this is one square touching g
there are other squares that touch this
edge from g
to a through g right this edge
you can also take another b for example
you can take from g to g b2
and from a3g to a3 gb2
now it sounds not like a programmer
anyway you get this square and you can
also move to the third b neighbor
like this
and you see here that you got three
pages in the book whose spine is this
edge
okay and more generally you can see that
the neighbors
that the the squares the touch g
can be arranged uh i hope you see it in
this a by b matrix
okay where the square corresponding to i
don't know this location is the square
that is called a1
g
and b2
because i took this row in this column
okay this is already getting very messy
okay so all the squares touching g can
be arranged in an a by b matrix
and
[Music]
what else should i say about this
um
okay and the squares that touch an
entire edge correspond to either a
column or a row in this matrix
this column corresponds to this edge and
this row corresponds to this edge
okay
any questions so far
is it okay is it possible that four
versus in one of the original graphs
yes yes yes good question so the
question was maybe this graph has many
other four cycles
we don't care we only care about the
ones that we you know that alternate in
colors and
are of the kind we define
uh what kind of groups give these
explicit examples uh okay so uh
these are like the major like
two by two matrix groups like the kind
that give the lps expanders
more accurately the higher dimensional
ones like the electric expanders so
these are think of uh
particular two by two matrices or some
large fields
these are the groups
that you can use for these um
graphs any more questions
do we need uh
an assumption to guarantee that gp1 is
not equal or does it not matter right so
we
we talked about that and no okay you
asked g b one not equal to a g b two
uh
all these non-conjugacy things will
will take care of it
okay
ah okay so finally i just want to remark
that
maybe now this explains the graphic
better you have all these squares and
they're kind of
one touching the other and it's kind of
a very complicated
mess but when you look just at the local
pieces of this mess then you can put
some
order into it
and
i also want to comment that um
this specific construction is an example
of the square complex
square complexes are very well studied
and you also have cubicle complexes
meaning higher dimensions than just
squares
you can easily construct them just by
taking cartesian product of graphs you
will get such
if you take two graphs you're going to
get a square complex if you take more
you're going to get a d dimensional
cubicle complex
but we also know of better constructions
than just products constructions that
are roman nujan for the correct
definition of that
somehow other constructions that we know
in this world study didn't give us what
we need whereas this construction does
give it to us it's very curious that
telegraphs have been studied for
maybe over 100 years but uh i don't
i well i don't know if these objects
were
looked at before and were useful
so
[Music]
curious okay
so now i finished talking about the
square
the left right daily complex and i want
to talk about the code
so maybe let's check if there are any
more questions
[Music]
okay we answered all the questions
oh it looks like it
okay
okay so let's define the code so
um
just like in the expander codes we
had two components an expander graph in
a base code
here we're gonna have uh two components
the square complex the scaly left right
tail complex and the base code so we're
going to have two base codes one for the
a generators and one for the b generator
so c a and c b
and
and you can assume that a equals b in
size
so that you can take just one code c
naught and have c and c b just be copies
of xenon
uh and then you define the code you're
gonna put the bits on the squares so
what i mean by that is that your code
words are going to be functions that
label every square with a bit those
functions from the squares to bits just
like before we add functions from the
edges to bits
so that's the code words and they have
to have some kind of constraints so the
constraints are going to be given by
edges every edge
is going to look around at all the
squares around it so like all the pages
in the book
of this edge
and it's going to require that these
bits line up to be an element in the
basically
and remember there was a question that
said do you need to order the edges in
the expander graph because how are you
going to know if it's in the base code
maybe the bits are like this or maybe
they're like that so
here we have a natural ordering using
the the daily generators
so formally this is the definition of
the code
and so let's say read it slowly the code
contains all functions
on the squares to zero one
such that
for every edge of the form ggb
when you let a run freely so for all
values of a what you see here is a
function from the set a to zero one
this function needs to be in ca
so geometrically it means that you have
an edge you look at all the book around
this edge it lines up you you order it
according to a
and then this needs to be in ca
and symmetrically
when you fix an edge of the form g a g
and you let b run freely
this is a function on the set b and this
needs to be in cb
okay so this is the definition of the
code
now that we have the code defined we can
start asking what is the rate what is
the distance look at the stability
and so on
so let's talk about the rate
the rate analysis is exactly like we had
in the case of the expander codes well
not exactly but
conceptually it's exactly the same
you to prove that the rate is a positive
you just need to see how many degrees of
freedom you have
so the ambient the original degrees of
freedom is the number of squares
how many do i have i have
how many triples do i have i have g
times a times b that's the number of
rooted squares and i need to divide by
four
that's the number of squares
and then i need to subtract the number
of constraints
maybe some constraints are not
independent that's only going to be in
my favor so this is only a lower bound
so
i have eight constraints and i have b
constraints for every a edge so how many
a edges do i have i have g a
divided by two
for every a edge
uh
i'm going to have the constraint that
this set of squares needs to be in the b
code so how many constraints define the
b code it's b times one minus
r naught
pretend that i choose the same synonyms
for both a and b
and also allow me not to write
cardinalities in every place because it
will be hard to read
okay and
symmetrically i also have all the b
constraints so for every b edge this is
the number of the edges
i have a constraint that you belong to
the code c a
so the number of such constraints are a
times 1 minus r naught
and if i just open this up and i do the
calculation i get
that you get g times a times b
divided by 4 that's the number of
squares times 4 are not minus 3. so
that's exactly what i have here because
i need to divide by the number of
squares so i need to remove this
when i normalize and i get that the rate
is positive whenever r naught is above
three quarters
previously we needed or not to be above
half now we just need it to be above
three quarters
what about the distance
so i'm not going to do it now but the
distance follows the propagation
argument just like before uh
suppose you have some nonzero code word
so there's some square that's non-zero
look at that uh a vertex touching this
square
or look at an edge touching this square
this edge must have many other non-zeros
because ca the code there
has positive
distance so this means that other
squares are non-zero and you keep
propagating and you see that there is
some
positive distance of course i do need
expansion for this propagation to work
so i do need the delta naught is bigger
than lambda
this was the same
issue that we had in expander code and
maybe i forgot to say then i'll say it
now
nice way to think about expander codes
and counter codes that is that
if your base code has some property like
distance then the expansion allows you
to globalize this property and have the
entire code have the same property
distance
okay
so these were nice nice things and we
already had them in the case of the
one-dimensional expander code let's look
at something that's new here
uh the local views from the point of
view of the vertices so the claim here
is that the local views are
tensor codes
so what are the local views remember
this picture where we had a vertex and
we looked at all the squares touching
the vertex and they were lined up in
this
a by b matrix
so the claim is that if i look at these
squares and i put them in this a by b
matrix
the local view that i'm going to see is
going to be of a tensor code so formally
i'm starting with
a word in the code okay so it's a
labeling of all these words with bits
and now i fix some vertex g
and i look at this part of the word so i
look i fix g and i let a run freely and
b run freely and that's how i place
these bits in this matrix okay this is
just defining a matrix for me
and the claim is that this local view
must belong to the code ca tens or cb if
you're not familiar with this notation
it just means that all the columns are
in ca and all the rows are in cd this is
the definition of the standard problem
and this is really just from the
definition i copied here the definition
and notice that i fixed b
meaning that i i fixed some column
and i let a run free
and the definition says it must be in ca
and this part says that if i fix a so
i'm fixing a row and i let b run freely
i must be incident
it's a basic that the local view is a
tensorflow
that's interesting because tensor codes
have
non-trivial dependencies between their
constraints
you know for example um
oh i won't say any more than that but so
here is the theorem the theorem says
uh if you start with a cayley
left right k complex
that is a lambda expander
that's one condition that you need
and if
your base code c a and c b are locally
testable so here i wrote row robustly
testable i'll say what that is in a
minute
so if these two conditions hold and
there is
correct relationship so
the expansion is sufficiently small with
respect to
both the local distance and the local
local testability
if these two things hold
then the resulting code is locally
testable
okay so it's very similar to the case of
expander codes there you said
if the local
code has good distance and there is some
relationship lambda is less than delta
naught the distance globalizes and here
you're adding this extra thing if the
local code also has
local testability
and there is some relation then this
also globalizes
this is really like in line with this
philosophy of high dimensional expansion
where the expansion can be used to lift
things
globally
so when you say something is locally
testable let's say what the test is
going to be so the test is this select a
random vertex uniformly
and then you read your given code word
this function on the on the squares on
all the squares that touch this vertex
so basically you just read this entire
little matrix
maybe i forgot to emphasize let me just
say it again
when we think of a kelly complex we
think of a and b as constant and the
size of the group goes to infinity
okay so this is like a constant number
of bits and the graph is
going to the size of the graph is huge
so you read this entire little matrix
and of course how do you accept the
reject you accept if it belongs to the
tensorflow
so that's the test and what is the main
thing that we need to prove
it's this inequality it says
that the probability the fraction of
vertices g
on which the local view
fails to be a tensor
code word
this fraction is an upper bound
to the distance of f from the code
so you can't have a situation where
f is only a
failing on a few local views but somehow
it's very far from the code
this is something that happened earlier
but in this situation
you can't have it and notice also that
unlike in the tanner codes you see
okay sorry this code is a tanner code
we saw the factor graph so this code is
a terrible but it's not a
an expander code like the substrate
experiment codes were
and indeed
there you could have c not be different
at every location
here i can't have that
because
uh even if i change the constraints
around the
if i change the constraints around one
edge still the fact that i require this
entire thing to be a tensor code it
implies that this
the this will satisfy also the
constraints that i
removed
up
uh let's see so any more questions
okay so i'm pretty pretty it went pretty
slowly
uh when did we start how long do i have
um can you hear me uh
why don't you take four minutes so two
minutes over
okay all right so let me skip this um
this is the
this is explaining what exactly is the
condition on the base code that you need
to make to satisfy the theorem
not every basically works but a random
ldpc codes are going to work and i'm
going to skip that
i wanted to show some proof of local
testability but i feel
like okay i'm just going to
kind of go over the algorithm
so how do you prove that something is
locally testable you start with a word
that you know has some probability of
rejection
and in your proof or
at least in this proof
you you show an algorithm to reconstruct
a nearby codeword
and this algorithm is really like a
simple
self-correction algorithm
so let's let's look at the algorithm
you start with the word first step for
every vertex you look at the entire
local neighborhood of the vertex and you
find an actual tensor code word that's
closest to
to the view that you see the view that
you see doesn't have to be a valid code
word so you correct it in some way
but then the different local
local views might disagree with each
other and so you define a progress
measure which is the number of edges
that are in dispute
so g thinks something and g prime the
neighbor and something else this edge is
in dispute
and then you do this local correction
where every vertex looks at its
neighbors
and
sees and thinks you know maybe i can
change my entire tensor code word
to be in better agreement with my
neighbors if
you can do that go ahead
and keep doing it until you're stuck
at this point
if there's no more disagreement zero
disagreement
that's it we're happy
we can output the
code word and that's actually
what we prove is that if the probability
of rejection was small you will never be
stuck
we prove it in the other way we say that
if um
oops
if you're stuck
must be
that the rejection is very high
okay now i'm a bit
out of time so i apologize but i
skipped this
trying to explain here
why the
local local stability
is required for the propagation to work
somehow to prove that the rejection must
be high you show that if there was even
one dispute edge there must be more
dispute age and more and more and more
like in the case of distance and so
there's a lot if you back stuck it means
there's a ton of rejection but for this
this won't work unless
the local code has some local local
disability okay i don't
i'm not going to do it
but okay so let me just kind of finish
uh so right so the main result is that
there exists our delta and q such that
an infinite family of local testable
codes and how do we do it from the
components that we discussed
so we start with a family of base codes
like random ldpc codes that have high
enough rates
and
constant robustness is this local
disability property and constant delta
distance
then you choose lambda to be small
enough with respect to these parameters
and then you choose a family of left
right ka complexes for this small lambda
this dictates the size this say the size
of a n and b and it's some constant d
that depends on lambda which depends on
delta n
and then uh
you
you output
the code which is based on the kali
complexes together with the base code
which you choose on on length d
okay so
you can do it
uh
okay so to finish let me just say some
high level thoughts
about a high dimensional expansion
the idea of using high dimensional
objects here we have these squares
a
to
construct ltc's instead of just the
one-dimensional expanders this idea has
been around for a few years
uh
as we said it started from these
high-dimensional expanders which have
this marvelous logo to global features
and
i first learned about it from italy
kaufman and it was obvious that this is
very interesting it also involves a lot
of areas of math that i didn't know a
lot about
initially we thought that this would
involve very complicated things but
somehow
uh things simplified
uh i think it could have been much worse
than it is
there have been a lot of works showing
this local to global and although this
work doesn't use these specific objects
it does use the same
ideology i guess
and
specifically we had this work that
started in the summer cluster
at berkeley
with the harsha and once they indicted
where we proved that if you define a
code on a high dimensional expander and
locally it's an ltc and there's some
other extra
agreement tests it's a technical
condition then you can globalize and
prove that the entire thing is an htc
and uh this paper i think is really what
uh
gave us confidence in this work to kind
of push and try to to get this ltc it
didn't have very good faith in terms of
it got rejected from plenty of
conferences but i guess it was hard to
believe that this program will
materialize somehow for us i think we
did believe it and recently also i saw a
similar schema in a recent paper by
gotham in openheim
uh
so the main problem that we were facing
was how to instantiate this idea of
defining a local code and globalizing
when you actually try to do it it's very
difficult we had some conjectures we
couldn't manage to do it and luckily
this whole
square complexes with these tensors
was a way to circumvent these
difficulties i think this is still a
super interesting question
so here are some questions
uh
uh can you materialize that hope of
constructing codes on the
broad teeth quotient buildings whatever
that's one question another question is
about these uh left right complexes
which are new objects and kind of
interesting
is there a three-dimensional version for
these or more dimensional uh it seems
that this is very strongly relying on
this left right
multiplication but
i don't know
and of course the last question is uh
you know
ltc's came from pcps for a long time
people believe that they're related and
you can always do them together
can you use these things to construct
pcps
i don't know
okay
first of all thank you very much
[Applause]
beautiful result and talk and i um even
though we're out of time
uh
are there any questions in the audience
here
i have a
question go for it
so so a
beautiful result so
it sounds like you're not actually using
high dimensional expansion anymore it's
just basic graph expansion right
um
it's based on just basic graph expansion
but there is something uh that's high
dimensional in that when you analyze the
local testability the part that i
skipped
you analyze a walk that goes from edge
to parallel edge
and it goes from an edge to a square to
the parallel edge in the square so to me
that's like a higher dimensional walk
because you're not going through the
vertices
but yeah i don't know
any other questions i guess there was a
question which is uh is your paper
publicly available and i think earlier
people asked if you would
uh give us your slides we definitely
will post your recorded talk yeah i
definitely will give the slides and the
paper is like almost
it's not publicly available yet i hope
to get it by the talk i apologize but
maybe in a couple of weeks i'm giving
another talk at the
in
a couple of weeks at iis will be more
detailed and by then i really hope the
paper will be out
okay absolutely great and thanks again
and thank you elite and everybody for uh
joining
thank you
bye bye
[Music]